et un britannique sont enfin parvenus à
un accord mais c'est à la fin de la
foire qu'on compte les bouses a expliqué
bruno le maire
une bien longue de foire pour un bon
deal la chambre des communes va-t-elle
voter ce deuxième texte
rien n'est moins sûr alors boris johnson
a t'il bien joué en fin de compte ou
bien est il en voie de teresa
mobilisation on écoute le premier
ministre britannique a à nouveau fait
comme un réflexe langue de bois
le spring and taken by by side emmanuel
macron lui est moins catégorique on
écoute également
oui en effet une une bonne nouvelle ce
matin avec la finalisation d'un accord
qui apparaît comme positif à la fois
pour eux union européenne et pour le
côté britannique
maintenant il convient de passer les
prochaines étapes et instruit par le
passé eu il faut rester raisonnablement
prudent
cet accord permet je crois de répondre
aux préoccupations politiques technique
était à la fois les nôtres et celle des
britanniques
nous allons nous réunir cet après midi
il y aura ensuite des éléments de
ratification évidemment à prendre un
moment de ratification au parlement
britannique et européen
et c'est à ce moment là que les choses
pourraient être finalisées mais à ce
stade
ou peut être que satisfait en tout cas
que les négociations et plus
aboutir à quelque chose de positif
répondre pourquoi occupation je veux
vous remercier nos négociateurs et tout
particulièrement mais c'est le dernier
pour pour cela satisfait mais prudent
alors est-ce qu'il vaut mieux que
theresa may ce qu'il fait mieux boris
johnson matthey brocade et je pense que
c'est un peu tôt pour se poser la
question et et se prononcer maintenant
vous l'avez dit tout le monde le répète
on va déjà attendre samedi de voir si ça
passe à la chambre des communes a donc
le parlement britannique
parce que bon ben si on prend l'exemple
de theresa may c'est quand même pas
passer trois fois les unionistes
d'irlande du nord parvenus au meilleur
accord est ce qu'il est parvenu à
améliorer encore ben je sais pas j'ai
pas tout à fait sûr vu le la note que va
devoir régler le royaume-uni pour la
sortie vu que une petite concession sur
l'irlande du nord meilleurs accords je
sais pas ce qui est sûr c'est qu'on n'y
est pas encore en fait odile pour
l'instant il ya un deal qui a eu lieu
entre le premier ministre britannique et
le négociateur en chef de l'union
européenne celle barnier on va attendre
de voir si ça passe le parlement pour
des rares personnes ça fait déjà deux
personnes y en a beaucoup d'autres à
convaincre marin de viry qu'est ce que
vous en pensez
alors je pense que c'est un bon
négociateur mais ça veut pas dire que la
négociation va réussir
c'est un bon négociateur parce que bon
négocier c'est arrivé au terme
enfin arrivés à un accord dont les
termes favorisent les intérêts que vous
représentez quoi ça
or si on prend ce qui existe aujourd'hui
qui est sur la table entre lui et la
grande bretagne
c'est ce que probablement on pouvait
faire de mieux en matière d'intérêts
mutuels maintenant on sait pas si ça va
aboutir parce qu'il ya non seulement
l'irlande que vous venez de citer mais
il ya également les cos et puis après il
abat disons que l'ensemble des points
c'est à dire à la fois le traitement des
personnes le traitement des capitaux le
traitement des produits le traitement
des services et ses stars ont été cadrés
et puis on sait qu'on va vers
au fond ce que sera demain le statut de
la suisse par rapport à une union
européenne c'est à dire au fond un grand
accord cadre commercial dans lequel vos
fonds fera fonctionner bilatéralement
les les choses avec un système assez
complexe de douaniers entre la france et
l'angleterre en raison justement du
facteur irlandais mais complexe mais qui
techniquement parait-il d'après les
experts peut tenir bon alors ça veut pas
dire que politiquement ça va passer mais
en tout cas ça veut dire qu'il ya un
accord et que de ce point de vue là
c'est un c'est un bon négociateur ce
qu'ils sont pas au détriment des
intérêts de la grande bretagne ni
d'ailleurs de l'union européenne et
c'est vrai que barnier est à saluer à la
fois pour son professionnalisme et son
côté bienveillant dans l'affairé hamon
c'est très clair voilà simplement je
vois le toute la difficulté maintenant
c'est de savoir si ça va aller au bout
et ça ça c'est tout à fait d'accord mais
il n'a pas l'air de convaincre son camp
pour autant non non non il ne convainc
pas son camp pour autant la situation
est très difficile du côté du parti
conservateur
les travaillistes sont en embuscade il a
une sorte de d'opposition extrême qui
dit qu'au fond cet accord n'est pas en
accord de break site et il a une opinion
publique qui s'attend quand même à ce
qu'il y ait une réalisation delà de la
volonté démocratique qui a été exprimée
il ya trois ans il ya trois ans et demi
donc il est dans une situation
intérieure extraordinairement difficile
alors donc c'est pour toutes ces raisons
c'est un intérieur plus écossaises et
irlandaises si on considère que ces
intérieurs si je fais déjà extrêmement
difficile
marc votre avis sur la situation
j'ai bien progressé mais peut-être pas
autant j'ai l'impression d'un retour en
arrière parce que de mémoire la date du
31 octobre pour le brésil a déjà été
reculée donc saisir trouver exactement
dans cette situation où un accord avait
été arraché à la dernière minute avant
un conseil européen et juste avant la
deadline qui avait été fixée je crois
que c'était en mars ouvrant au printemps
dernier il ya l'époque c'était encore
theresa may qui était premier ministre
et elle avait dit exactement la même
chose que bourré de sun odyssey est un
excellent accord le meilleur qu'on
puisse trouver
on a vu comment ça c'est fini et juste
pour l'anecdote au delà du fond sur
lequel j'ai pas énormément de
compétences mais il se trouve que au
figaro à trois mètres de moi j'ai
florentin colons florentin collomb il a
été correspondant du figaro pendant huit
ans à londres et donc le brick city
connaît par coeur et même
il n'y comprend rien il est revenue des
derniers en france il a d'abord assuré
tout franchement il lui ne veut parier
sur rien j'arrête pas lui dire à léon
paris ça passe ça passe pas ne veut
mettre la roucarié quoi marque à moi je
sais je sais mais c'est juste pour le
plaisir du jeu mais lui c'est un
spécialiste de ces questions là et même
lui complètement paumé et incapable de
prédire temps comment vont réagir les
uns que quelques vont voter les autres
là je pense que la politique britannique
est devenue complètement folle avec
cette histoire de brigitte depuis trois
ans et demi et bien inspiré et celui qui
va dire ce qui va se passer on va parier
internaute sur twitter
mais moi je suis assez d'accord sur le
fait qu' il ya prés l'éthique intérieur
majeur à londres avec son on a
l'impression d'avoir déjà vécu cette
séquence effectivement avec cette
différence que boris johnson il est
arrivé au pouvoir en disant je peux
sortir même sans accord est donc toute
sa difficulté ça va être d'expliquer aux
britanniques en quoi cet accord que
finalement il signe et si différent de
celui qu'avait obtenu theresa may parce
que sinon on a perdu un an pour rien ou
alors il a menti encore une fois
peut-être pour décrire vos places au
peuple britannique pour des questions
d'opportunité politique donc il va
devoir faire la preuve que cet accord
est vraiment un accord comme vous le
dites de briques site mais très
différent de celui theresa may moi je
suis pas rentré dans les centaines de
pages de l'accord mais mes 6 ans voilà
si on voit bien à peu près ce que ce que
dit la presse aujourd'hui j'ai pas
l'impression qu'il y est en tout cas un
clivage si important que ça entre
l'accord de theresa may et celui de
boris johnson et puis la deuxième chose
quand même moi qui me qui m'intéresse
c'est la réaction de des états membres
européens notamment des modèles macron
le break si ce n'est pas qu'une affaire
politique britannique
ça va devenir si effectivement cet
accord pertur peut-être qu'on peut lui
donner une chance et peut-être qu'on va
aller au bout mais ça va devenir aussi
une affaire politique française et
européenne parce que les opinions
publiques européennes pour l'instant ne
se sont pas exprimés sur les conditions
de la sortie de l'union européenne et de
ce que de l'union européenne la grande
bretagne ce que ça signifie pour eux en
termes d'efforts en termes de
consentement et puis aussi en termes
d'opportunités et là on n'a pas eu ce
débat politique en france
et moi j'ai peur que la prochaine étape
est le prochain blocage politique
ils soient plus nécessairement
britannique même si
n'est pas encore franchi mal mais il
n'est pas encore franchi les loin d'être
franchi mais derrière ça il faut qu'on
pense aussi à l'opinion publique et aux
débats politiques en europe et notamment
en france sur ce sujet si on n'était pas
dedans on n'est pas à l'abri pardon je
gardais 28 de l'union europé dix bougies
soient d'accord négocié par michel
barnier au monde avec les termes du
contrat sont pas les mêmes et il faut
lutter par l'irlande pour l'instant on
n'a pas vu de notre protestation non
mais parce que de toute façon il ya le
vote d'abord aux communes qui doit
passer après se prononceront le reste et
là on pose la question de savoir est ce
que boris johnson est un bon négociateur
d'abord rappelons nous que la majeure
partie de cet accord n'a pas été négocié
par boris johnson quand même donc est-ce
que c'est lui le monde scotia tort je ne
fais pas mal et lausanne exposé la
semaine vous un peu payante tête par
mois je la question qu'on te disais
bruit la question pourrait se poser sur
sa capacité de négociation
c'est quand ils vont commencer la vraie
négociation à savoir avec l'avion mais
surtout quel est l'accord qui va y avoir
entre le royaume uni et l'union
européenne
parce que là on n'est que sur l'accord
de son alors là il faut rappeler qu'en
vérité c'est qu'un accord car ce n'est
qu'ensuite après il faut pendant de
longs mois négocié toutes les modalités
sa transition comment luc soete on est
là on va reprendre entre l'union
européenne et le royaume uni thématique
par thématique
on repart de zéro et là on va pouvoir se
poser la question de s que boris johnson
est un bon négociateur et est-ce que
l'accord donc et de nombreux mois
maintenant qu'il aura peut-être lui
peut-être pas lui d'ailleurs négocier
pour son pays sur les relations avec
l'eau avec l'union européenne
là c'est la question ne se posera
vraiment il a quand même une comment
dirais-je est un facteur favorable 5 e
on a envie de tourner la page
tout le monde a envie de tourner la page
y compris les politiciens britanniques
parce que ça fait quand même trois ans
et demi que la jambe d'un politique
britannique tourne autour de ça ça fait
quand même trois ans et demi
parallèlement que les institutions
européennes ne parlent que de ça et que
ça consomme une énergie psychique et
politiques si je peux dire absolument
considérables et donc le désir de
tourner la page pour rentrer dans des
négociations concrètes et non plus des
négociations sur comment dirais-je
le cadre de sorties phares voir jaillir
de toutes parts enfin du moins je
l'espère faso votre respect à vois
certains débats la cheminée comme
totalement partagée par tous les
hockeyeurs sont peut-être les derniers
feux l'irrationnel comme mâcon vous être
raisonnablement optimiste formule alors
nos internautes qu'en pense-t-il
comme quoi la menace d'un odile
apparemment fait un peu bouger les
choses estime site celui qui est aussi
dans le camp des raisonnablement
optimiste nicole en revanche se demander
si le parlement britannique ne signe pas
que se passe-t-il oui que se passe-t-il
alors que l'accord à touba il se passe
il n'y a pas beaucoup d'options soit
soit boris johnson va au bout de sa
logique politique quand il faut être sa
promesse et il sort sans accord embrasé
après tout il a été encore une fois il
est tard il entend par l'institutionnel
et ça lui seul le sait et en tout cas
les quelques députés qui font la
jonction entre la majorité et la
minorité lesavre une personne n'est
capable de dire ce qui va arriver
soit on repart dans une négociation
parce que pousse l'union ayant repas et
on repousse la date de toute façon cet
accord prévoit déjà une transition qui
va jusqu'à fin 2020 donc on a du temps
on
on a du temps pour faire sortir le
royaume-uni cg personne n'est si pressé
que ça tout le monde veut trouver un
accord qui soit politiquement acceptable
mais il n'y a pas tant d'options que ça
voilà boris johnson et quand même s'est
mis dans un corner politiquement assez
compliqué bon le break site on n'a pas
fini d'en parler babineau nous fait
remarquer ce fiasco du bric site arrange
beaucoup les affaires de l'union
européenne c'est un fantastique outil de
dissuasion enfin on peut pas en sortir
la question c'est quand c'est comment on
y rentre notre deuxième sujet ce soir
christophe castaner dira peut-être à son
tour ce qu'il pense du port du voile
invité de france 2 le ministre de
l'intérieur tentera en tout cas de
remonter la pente
un an tout juste après sa nomination il
a accumulé une série de faux